merci monsieur le président plus grands
plusieurs grands ports français sont à
l'heure où nous parlons bloqués c'est
l'opération portmore lancée pour
protester contre la réforme des
retraites dans certains ports pour
reprendre l'expression des manifestants
rien ne sort rien ne rentre et cela dure
parfois depuis deux mois la situation
qu'engendre ce conflit est une véritable
catastrophe économique pour toute la
chaîne logistique transporteurs routiers
transitaires et commissionnaires de
transport sont les premiers touchés
mais ce ne sont pas les seules certaines
usines sont en mal d'approvisionnement
et le secteur agricole voit ses
exportations compromise les conséquences
économiques vont bien au delà des
entreprises de transport sans les ports
il n'y a pas de commerce extérieur les
navires se détournent vers d'autres
ports européens et les efforts mis en
oeuvre pour développer les ports
français se retrouvent remise en cause
comme le faisait remarquer ce matin à
chef d'entreprise on est en train
d'enterrer les ports français
la situation devient difficilement tna
pour les entreprises notamment les pme
nous assistons à la multiplication des
mises en chômage technique
alors monsieur le ministre quelles
mesures comptez vous prendre pour venir
en aide à toutes les entreprises
touchées par un conflit auquel elles ne
sont pas partie prenante
quel soutien financier concret le
gouvernement entend t-il débloquer ces
questions les entreprises voulaient
pause
elles attendent un signal fort